since this film is now become it's a
Wonderful Life as opposed to one of the
films that you were in when you were
kids there was it was there a time when
you suddenly realized that this was
gaining steam or that it was being
rediscovered what do you remember when
that was or wasn't that for me it was
1980 somebody knocked on my door and
they said I'm living in Kansas they said
can we get an interview with you were
you that little girl and movie It's a
Wonderful Life
yeah I was and they said well we'd
really like to talk to you so I said
okay so I brought all my stuff up from
the basement and we had an interview the
next week the same thing happened and
then it happened again and again I
finally thought my goodness what's going
on here and then I started getting fan
mail and I'm 40 years old I haven't
thought about the movie industry because
I was orphaned at the age of 15 and sent
back to Missouri so you know that was a
part of my past I rarely thought about
and all of a sudden fan mail so I have
to admit that I actually sat down and I
watched the movie when I was 40 years
old first time I ever saw it and I
really felt like it was a piece of film
history at that time I knew what they
were talking about and I feel so
grateful that I was a part of that film
and that I could be that little girl
Zuzu and have that special line at the
end of the movie
daddy teacher says every time a bell
rings an angel gets his wings it's a
piece of film history and I believe it
Jimmy how about you do you remember when
you saw that this was gaining or when
was the first time you saw the film well
I kind of caught the fever with
everybody else but Paul Peterson and I
were sitting on the board of the Donna
Reed Foundation there was a festival in
her hometown for like 25 years we did
this and the the movie was so popular
and everything i sat down with Paul
because we wanted to make some sort of
donation for the Donna Reed Foundation I
said you know everybody thinks they know
everything about It's a Wonderful Life
why don't we write a trivia book and
we'll ask all the interesting things we
know some ins and outs that nobody else
knows and so we sat down that was like
1992 s when we were first really aware
that a lot of people liked this film and
I remember you know going to the
publisher and everything and they liked
it very much and the book did extremely
well and but ninety about ninety-two
this one I found out that it was very
special even called me ha ha
had you not heard from him did you did
you stay in contact or was it kind of
refined in each other Hollywood days
were over it was done but he contacted
me about the book yeah and then from
then on we've been sort of buddies you
might say yeah and then of course with
Janie we went on the target tour and the
Bailey kids were reunited that's right
we traveled all over the United States
yes and in fact we even traveled for
Walgreens and we rang the bell the new
arm Stock Exchange that was a real
that's cool I got to do the bill big
honor
Carol when did you get back in the swing
with this when did you remember or what
did you remember of the film well we
were living up in the mountains and we
had moved from Testim and some friends
called and said what we heard somehow
that this movie is looking for Jamie and
I know you were in it in the and they're
going to have you know a reunion and get
together and it's about I'm not
interested
I really wasn't at first Kentucky we had
moved up there and started a nice life
up in Crestline but I I was contacted
and kind of bugged to do it it was
lodged with my arm you know twist my arm
so anyway I did say yes I'd come down
and meet these people and meet the
people at Target and see what this was
all about and they they wanted us to be
in a parade the parade on Hollywood
Boulevard the Hollywood link rate well I
lived on Hollywood Boulevard and when I
was younger three blocks east of Vine
Street and I knew what they were talking
button and I used we used to park cars
in our back yard for the parade and so
then we passed that same place well yes
we did and the beautiful old house was
there so anyway I finally I agreed and
we we went on some trips we went to
Florida representing target we went all
over the United States then we've been
up to or against Colorado and we were
privileged to get to visit and have
dinner in Jimmy Stewart's hometown right
in his home and the people were so
gracious to us Indiana Pennsylvania and
yes Pennsylvania and visit the
University there and we also were able
to visit Donna Reid's hometown and right
in a parade I mean it we have really
truly had a wonderful life and we've
been blessed so much and visited many
different states and I've even met
this one man when we were signing
autographs this one young man who said
he knew every word in the script he had
memory memory in the movie he had
memorized everything and that incredible
yeah but it didn't changed his life that
much and I think it's changed a lot of
people's oh yes yeah it's well look
who's here if you love the movie or you
wouldn't be here
[Applause]